cet autre front la ville de severodonezk
c'est l'une des plus importantes du
dombass elle est encore sous contrôle de
craignant mais totalement encerclée par
les forces russes l'assaut sur place
semblent imminents on va écouter le
maire de la ville
la ville est presque encerclée par les
troupes russes et de la république
populaire de l'ogc ans
il essaie de prendre d'assaut la ville
depuis plusieurs endroits
le rythme d'évacuation est assez
misérable
c'est environ 10 personnes par jour que
nous avons réussi à convaincre de partir
c'est difficile car quinze mille
personnes restent dans la ville ils ne
veulent toujours pas en partir
malheureusement cette information ne
pousse pas les riverains à évacuer le
rythme des évacuations a
considérablement diminué